Auch so sieht Judentum heute
in Deutschland aus.
Helene Shani Braun ist queer,
bald Rabbinerin und auf Instagram aktiv.
Dort postet sie über Religion,
Sexualität und Berliner Lifestyle.
Und vertritt damit eine Generation,
die all das verbindet.
Was viele Menschen ja in der Schule
übers Judentum lernen,
ist ja wirklich furchtbar.
Also, sie lernen ja gar nichts.
Oder sie lernen was
über den Nationalsozialismus,
aber nicht über lebendiges Judentum,
wie es heute gelebt wird.
Und deswegen ist das auch so ein
bisschen dann mein Ziel geworden,
einfach so jüdisches Leben zu zeigen.
Helene ist religiös aufgewachsen.
Für sie sind einfach zu wenig
Frauen in hohen Ämtern.
Das will sie ändern.
Nach ihrem Studium wird
die 23-Jährige wahrscheinlich
die jüngste Rabbinerin Deutschlands sein.
Auch um eine Ansprechperson zu sein,
die sie selbst nie hatte.
Für mich ist ganz klar, dass niemand
sich zwischen seiner jüdischen
und seiner queeren Identität unterscheiden …
entscheiden soll,
denn du kannst es dir eben nicht aussuchen,
du wirst ja mit deiner Sexualität geboren oder
du entwickelst dich mit deiner Sexualität.
Und wenn du jüdisch bist,
dann sollst du auch beides leben können.
Dass man in der jüdischen
Gemeinschaft so weit gekommen ist,
ist auch Frauen zu verdanken
wie Gesa Ederberg.
Sie musste noch dafür kämpfen, überhaupt
als Rabbinerin anerkannt zu werden.
Es gab Leute,
die den Raum verlassen haben,
wenn ich ihn betreten habe.
Ich hab‘ dann irgendwann dafür gesorgt,
dass ich immer früh genug da war,
weil dann saß ich schon,
und dann mussten die anderen überlegen,
ob sie sich dazusetzen oder nicht.
Gesa Ederberg ist zum Judentum konvertiert.
Nun leitet sie die
Neue Synagoge in Berlin Mitte.
In Berlin gab es auch die erste
Rabbinerin überhaupt – Regina Jonas.
Sie war allerdings nur Religionslehrerin,
die zusätzlich rabbinisch-seelsorgerische
Betreuung übernehmen durfte.
Da ist sie. Und man sieht ja auch quasi
das Zentrale, was sie auch betont:
Gott hat nicht nach dem Geschlecht gefragt.
Also sie wollte einfach „Rabbiner-IN“ sein.
Sie blieb die einzige.
Das hat aber mit der Shoah zu tun.
Es gab wohl andere junge Frauen,
die in die gleiche Richtung
gedacht und geträumt haben.
Und für mich ist es einfach wunderbar,
nicht die erste zu sein.
Was immer mitschwingt
als Jüdin in Deutschland:
die Geschichte der Shoah.
Auch Regina Jonas wurde
von den Nazis ermordet.
Sie musste ihren Glauben
mit dem Leben bezahlen.
Und heute?
Der Antisemitismus ist lauter geworden,
ist vor allem auch unverschämter geworden
und versteckt sich ja häufig hinter so einem:
„Man muss doch noch mal sagen dürfen.“
Judentum heute ist so vielfältig wie seit
Jahrzehnten nicht mehr in Deutschland.
Leute wie Helene wollen sich das
nie wieder nehmen lassen.